bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france comment vous
accueillez ces nouvelles dégradations
sur la fresque en hommage à sts et je
les accueille pas pas forcément bien
j'ai été beaucoup plus marquée la
première fois là je me suis dit que de
toute façon vu le contexte et vu que ce
sont des actes quand même trail dash
anonyme
de toute façon ça allait se répéter
pourquoi est-ce que selon vous cette on
dégrade cette fresque on la dgrad parce
que steve est devenu malgré lui un
symbole un symbole delà de la violence
policière un soir de fête c'est devenu
aussi parce que steve faisait partie de
l'été teufeurs que c'est une communauté
qu'on juge aussi marginale quand je suis
différente de nous enfin voilà donc sur
laquelle on peut aussi s'acharner qu'on
ne comprend pas bref c'est devenu un
je pense que steve est devenu bien
malgré lui un symbole et pour moi ce
type de toute façon est au-dessus autres
bien au delà de tout y est ces bassesses
et ses ignominies
vous avez des nouvelles de l'anc est en
cours non non non pas moi non
alors vous dites que steve est un
symbole de un symbole des violences
policières ce n'est pas le seul
aujourd'hui il ya d'autres affaires qui
ramène justement à des violences
policières présumées auxquelles regard
vous portez par exemple sur ces
mouvements que l'on voit dans la rue
initiée par le comité justice pour adama
traoré
j'ai pas forcément de regard particulier
moi j'ai j'étais loin de tout ça pendant
un temps jusqu'à ce que ça me rattrape
mois au sein de ma vie de tous les jours
et effectivement je pense qu'ils aient
bas ça arrive ça arrive c'est des choses
qui arrivent qui devrait pas se passer
des choses qu'il faut dénoncer tout le
monde tous les policiers sont pas
pareils mais il y a des gens qui n'y
sont pas bien dans tous les corps de
métier et il faut dénoncer ce qui se
passe c'est tout et la justice dans tout
cela
la justice est là elle a un autre
un autre temps on va dire un autre c'est
pas du tout là enfin voila moi j'attends
quelque chose de la justice je sais pas
à quoi je dois m'attendre mais j'espère
quand même en la justice mais je sais
que ça va prendre beaucoup beaucoup de
temps merci beaucoup à vous anne claire
agira je rappelle que vous êtes une amie
de steve merci pour cette réaction